- It's time for Drew's News,
the only news with the portable
desk, including a mess.
And with me at the traveling
desk is my trusty co-pilot,
and just one of the loves of
my life, "Rossi" Ross Matthew.
- Hi, hi everybody!
(audience cheers)
- And this season, our motto
is, "have desk will travel".
As you can see, Ross and I are taking
our little news show on the
road all across America,
and I'm thrilled to kick it
off right here in my hometown,
right in front of the
Hollywood sign, I mean,
how crazy is that?
- See I love this, Drew,
you know, I thought we
had fun in season one,
now we are on the road,
so watch out America, we're coming.
- We'll be doing this all season long,
so, if you want the desk in your hometown,
we would like you to reach
out to us and let us know.
Send us a message on
social media and tell us
where the desk should go next.
- Maybe we'll be in your town, watch out.
- Okay, so for the last month
everyone's been asking one big question,
"splish, splash, should
we be taking less baths?"
Vogue reports that it's the
latest trend in Hollywood hygiene,
Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis
say that they only bathe
themselves and their
kids when they see dirt.
Dax Shepard and Kristen
Bell say their family
waits until they smell the stink!
- [Ross] Ugh, Oh!
- And Jake Gyllenhaal says he
barely showers because quote,
"we naturally clean ourselves"
and you know the ladies are like, "okay".
(audience laughs)
Ross, "to bathe or not to
bathe", that is the question,
what do you think?
- Do what you want,
if you want to save it
until you smell the stink
before you bathe, good for
you, but not Ross Matthews.
I don't play like that.
I don't know, like I just feel like I
can't be my best self unless
I smell artificially clean.
- What do you guys think, raise your hand
if you think that you don't
really need showers all the time.
- [Ross] Thank you!
(audience laughs)
Thank you!
- And by the way, I mean,
we have to acknowledge
the fact that someone
I am the biggest fan of,
Seth,
mister dude with sign.
I want to know, do you
have any bread crumbs
of a trail that traces back
to kind of how this really
started, Dude with sign
that now has 8 million
followers basically?
- Yes, so, basically I was
working for a card game company
and I was writing just like funny jokes,
and we were also trying to do
funny content every day just for fun.
And one day we tried one that said,
"stop replying all" to
company-wide emails.
We were, we were emailing and
it was someone's birthday.
And then everyone was replying
all those things like,
"oh my God, happy birthday, Jenna",
like it was just really annoying,
and we were like, "oh, we
should go protest this,
Seth, you'll do it",
and I was like, "I'll do it",
went out there and did it
and it blew up, everyone really liked it,
and I was just kinda like,
"we could probably keep doing this".
Yeah, it definitely worked out.
- And then you're hanging
out with Justin Bieber-
- [Seth] And Drew Barrymore, what's up?
- Oh, my god!
(Ross and audience laugh)
You also were just at the white house
in the Oval
- [Seth] Yeah.
- [Drew] Office with Biden.
- [Seth] Yes.
- All right, next step,
one of Hollywood's finest,
Christopher Maloney,
you know him, and recently he,
he was on the cover of Men's Health
looking like a total "Zaddy" at age 60,
he's 60 years old you guys,
but now the New York Post reports,
dictionary.com's just
added the word "Zaddy",
and it's defined as "An attractive
man who is also charming
and self-confident" and if you look it up,
my picture's right there.
No, it's not!
(Drew and audience laugh)
Chris Maloney says now that
he knows what it means,
he is happy to be America's zaddy.
Look at this zaddy, Chris Maloney.
- [Drew] Oh my gosh.
- All right, well, next up,
apparently it's not just Jen and Ben
who are getting back together.
A new relationship study
says many people hook up
with their exes, and you know what,
women, I didn't mean to point at you,
women...
(Ross laughs)
- Oh, we've all,
oh I've got around the bend with the exes,
of course, that's what we do.
- I was gonna ask you.
- It's 'cause you're convinced
that it's unrequited,
maybe you've changed,
maybe it's unfinished,
Anyway, keep going.
- Well women, women do
it more than men do,
and it sounds like you
are one of them, yeah.
Uh, Women and Homes says the study found
that 54% of women had slept with an ex,
while only 14% of them actually
wanted to get back together,
they were like, "I quit it,
but I can still hit it",
you know?
(audience laughs)
Well, Dude with the
sign, what do you think?
(Drew and audience laugh)
- And yet you can never tell
them because guess what,
the second they get back
together, you're in the doghouse.
- Yeah, mhmm.
- Now, this story is
my favorite of the day.
We've got some really great
news for students and families
right here in California.
CNN is reporting that
the state is offering
universal free lunch to all public school
students this fall.
(everyone applauds)
Nearly 60% of the students
qualify for free lunch
or reduced lunch, but this
year, thanks to the work
of over 200 organizations,
every student will get a
balanced, nutritious lunch,
free of charge and free of stigma.
California is the very first
state to get this done.
Not only am I so in awe of this,
I want to know how we can
take this across our country.
- Yes!
- California, thank you
for setting the bar.
May we all follow in your
footsteps and example.
(rousing, upbeat music)